[Music]
thank you thank you so I have a terrible
health insurance right now
my car has better insurance on me that's
right man next time I get sick I'm just
gonna you know get into a car accident
crash into a telephone pole you better
than action are you okay I have Crohn's
disease just happen I think it was the
airbag somebody change my diaper yeah so
people tell me all the time now well
health care isn't in the Constitution
it's not a right isn't in the
Constitution yeah I know that that's
because health care in the late 1700s
yeah kind of yeah wasn't that good they
even have ice that's how bad it was no
ice you got injured they just handed you
a bag of water put that on your leg wait
to the winter bad news is we all die in
a winter so it's sort of a catch-22
which is a book that wasn't written yet
so I'm in terrible health thank you I've
lived in LA about a year and a half now
I've developed a condition known as taco
tits
call this one carne asada someone play
itto a little bit smaller a lot of food
trucks yeah foods a tough one food it's
everywhere all of its legal I'm just
driving your car and get the worst food
for you bartenders they can cut you off
you've had too much to drink they should
have that same power at fast-food
restaurants order a cheeseburger you
pull around to the window the guy there
just has a long stick on it with
markings and just slowly pushes that in
your stomach till it stops
alright says here apple slices that's
all we can give yet we almost lost the
stick on that one I don't make good
choices
I can't even grocery shop properly
that's how bad it is it starts off good
Ryan just put fruits and vegetables in
the cart I'm gonna turn this life around
and I get to the register that's covered
up a bacon and pies need to redesign
grocery stores people like me with no
willpower keep the produce section the
same wide open wide aisles and then the
worst of the food gets you the you know
narrow the aisles gets so if you can't
fit in there you're not allowed to eat
that's I have a food
[Music]
after the ice-cream section it's this
why get some sort of CrossFit exercise
to fit in there waiting out in front of
the store hey skinny rocky road hook it
up come gotta send your kids in for
Cheetos three bags you're grounded yeah
I was gonna start eating organic food
yeah
then I went to a place that sells
organic food and realize you can't
afford anything in there unless you're a
millionaire you can just look around
like it's a museum or something I'm
gonna go to the celery exhibit next and
then take out a loan and get a carrot
yeah save enough first two they're
making us make decisions on our health
based on money we shouldn't have to do
that but that's yeah like all right and
get the organic grapes for $20 or and
get the grapes for down 99 sprayed with
poison I'm going with the poison grapes
got to pay rent so bag them up I'm gonna
rinse them off really good yeah my
friend told me rinse them off with
vinegar yeah that makes fruit taste
great thanks should I piss on my chicken
what else should I do Bobby Flay I don't
know why organic food costs more don't
they do nothing to it why would that
[Music]
yeah food that's bad here there's like
pesticides herbicides special machinery
to harvest it organic food I'm pretty
sure they just plant seeds and then it
hippie takes a dump on them that kick a
hacky sack in there alright that sixty
bucks get out of there but surely on
there to make that snow right they're
gonna know otherwise it's I say it's a
money thing but to be honest I have a
million dollars I would not start making
the correct decisions organic food would
not be my first stop I'd probably go to
a strip club for two or three days for
all these dancers free-range cuz yeah
that one's in a cage I'm worried about
her let's set her free
okay thank you very much
[Applause]
you